chris is an Atlanta hi Chris how are you
Dave I'm really scared but I'm really
happy to be talking to you thank you for
taking my call
absolutely how can I help sir so I have
made a lot of bad decisions I've a
mountain of debt and I have a
three-month-old and just discovered my
wife just a wife and I just discovered
we have another baby on the way
yay it's it's a it's a celebration but
it's just added to my my gift my
financial on peace I'm just calling for
help I don't even know where to start
gotcha so how much debt do you have sir
including the house five hundred and
twenty four thousand okay and how much
of that is the house three hundred okay
she have two hundred and twenty four
thousand non-mortgage yes yeah what is
that on so I have a thirty seven
thousand dollar truck note fourteen on a
sedan about fourteen hundred on a credit
card mm on left on a hospital bill that
were paying off for the newborn and my
wife has ninety and student loans and
then I have 80s as well as a Parent PLUS
mom and my name is not on the loan but
I've kind of committed to my parents I
would help with that with that note okay
so you so you've got one hundred and
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt and what does your what's your
wife's income sixty one okay and what's
yours 105 so the good news is we've got
a hundred and sixty six thousand dollars
in income and that's that's about the
change so my wife has high-risk
pregnancies um so last time around she
was out of work for the majority of
pregnancy so we're looking for our
income to actually go down here and
about a month or so okay that's part of
the stress alright I would put both the
student loans the Parent PLUS loan and
the student loan on hardship deferral
right now and I'd sell your truck okay
and let's get some these payments down
you need to get on a written budget and
what you have to do when you're doing a
budget that's super tight like this is
you start with what's most important
food the second thing is lights and
water the third thing is the house
payment so food shelter clothing
transportation utilities before you do
anything else you pay your car payments
you keep gassing the cars you keep going
to work and hopefully your wife can stay
employed this time but if not then we'll
deal with that and we'll work this
through I'd continue to push on this if
she's not back in the workplace
following the pregnancy you're going to
have to sell this house because it
doesn't fit and in here it fits with 160
it doesn't fit with 105 okay so you guys
have got to talk about that and I don't
care it either one's okay with me but
I'm just trying to get the math to work
for you but what happens is this if you
will lay down a written plan go to every
dollar calm download the app for your
iPhone or your Android and and you guys
put the stuff on put your monthly budget
together and do a unique budget each and
every single month okay a different
budget every month but some things don't
change your house payment doesn't change
your car payment doesn't change that
kind of stuff right hey but you lay out
that unique special this month we have a
plan
next month we have a plan every dollar
as an assignment every dollar has a
mission that's why we called it every
dollar every dollar calm okay okay and
when you do that you have more money
coming in then it feels like part of
your stress over half of your stress is
that you haven't laid all this stuff out
so it all is stressful but when you
write down and you know you've got the
money for food and you know you've got
the money for the house payment and you
know you got the money for the lights
and water and you know you got the money
for the car payment and you know you got
the money for this and you know you got
the money for that then there's you
limited your stress just to those things
that are towards the bottom of the list
do you follow me
all right and then you start to think
about how you can do things to increase
your income or what you can sell to get
this under control but if you sold the
truck which has what a $700 payment on
it just about yeah I have about 12,000
in equity in it though I could I was
thinking about selling and using that
12,000
by two cars cash and then sell her car
also I'm in I'm in that's also car
because that gets the stress off
obviously and here's the thing it's not
a permanent decision right it's a stupid
car if you notice there's cars on every
corner so we know it might truck but I
know but when you're making a hundred
and sixty-six thousand and you get this
mess cleaned up and you don't have any
payments but a house payment how fast
can you save up and buy a nice truck
real fast right but you got two kids you
got to take care of and right now you
just call me up completely overwhelmed I
could feel your throat being tight I
could feel it when you're talking to
them you know I know because I've been
there the year where you're Rachel was
born my daughter
it was a year I filed bankruptcy because
we lost everything so I know how it
feels to be that scared and have babies
on the way right and so you can do this
stuff you can absolutely do it and and I
tell you if if you want to hold on I'll
put you through Financial Peace
University and we'll walk with you
through this process you can turn this
around it's very very possible
if you ever do anything stupid have you
ever done a whole bunch of stuff stupid
if you didn't just raise your hand you
have a problem with lying don't you
we've all done it
me too but we don't have to keep doing
it we can change this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a five hundred thousand dollar
income
[Music]